um for you did you have any idea that
you were going to break Twitter when you
uh Flash the crowd when you're
performing
because you you own Twitter for about a
week oh my God no I did not I literally
was at my friend's party living my life
as I always do and you know I did not I
was having a good time I felt like I was
in a safe space right and that's it I
was honoring exactly how I was feeling
so yeah because like did you I mean you
had to have some sort of idea this is
gonna be on the internet a little bit I
was very shocked that I mean when aft
after after
I realized that there were so many
cameras you know because I try not to
live my life like I'm Janelle Monae
there are cameras let me let me let me
not yeah and and these and the party
that I was at was uh the same party that
inspired my album so I know a lot of the
people who were there and you know
they've been to to my place and we've
created a safe space with everyday
people and with Wonderland and our
parties and so
um it didn't really come out until like
that video was older it was old so
somebody was like well let me now
capitalize and that's the world we live
in yeah let me capitalize like it was
nobody posted anything safe space and
then when they sort of Saw
um
I think my visual that I put out they
were like oh well while we're here I saw
her laugh you know last week but it's
all love free the nipple free the nips
free the nipple I mean Rick Ross has
freed his nipple I support him you're
right about that D'Angelo when he did
Untitled he wasn't freed his nipple you
know what about from behind that piano
and freed the nipple you know I can go
on and on DJ Khaled has freed his
nipples many times right DJ Khaled you
know we support free the nipple right
for all people I agree yeah and it's a
double standard that t-shirt
yeah
and so it helped with the promotion
because now everybody's like I mean you
were trending like yeah you know listen
I live my life I think I never think
like oh this is going to get them
talking I'm having an earth experience
and of honoring all of me I love it
that's it that's all I can do
um give me if you're on an island
stranded for 365 days you can only bring
Five albums with you on an iPod now stop
it first of all an iPod I have not heard
that word you're not gonna have Wi-Fi
because you're going to be on an island
you're right you're right you use your
phone so I have to use well my iPod died
though though that's a hey okay I don't
know right okay
keep it keep it
she's like is there going to be sewage
well I'm definitely taking the age of
pleasure okay because I know that we
made that project to be on an island to
be on an island to transport me and if I
need a soundtrack to that to to that
that experience that I want to have
um
oh okay I have to take
some prints so maybe I'll take Purple
Rain all right
um he has so many albums I gotta take
some Stevie okay I gotta have some
comfort shout out to Stevie intervisions
or music of my mind one of those
um
I also would probably take just
soundtrack
um
I would take uh
some Harold bud
he has an album Harold Budd which is
like it puts me in a super meditative
space
um one more oh God this is tough this is
really really tough I don't even know
why I'm answering this I just feel like
I'm gonna be like why didn't I say that
album
um
what else would I take what else do I
what about a hip give me a hip-hop one
oh okay
um
maybe I might take
maybe I take the love below okay speaker
box love below take the double disc
that's it that's a nice Chicken Box
exactly I will take that because that's
like I remember wanting to make
like music like fun creative I remember
that was that that helped me tap into to
to my own uniqueness uh you mentioned
Stevie Wonder uh Stevie Wonder's
obviously obviously a fan of yours when
you meet Stevie Wonder what is that like
he said like I feel like he's got like
one of those people kind of like Prince
they feel like they might have an aura
you see around them for sure for sure
but also very funny such a jokester such
a trickster will say whatever's on his
mind
um I'm like you should let people see
more of this side of you because people
do put he I mean his music is like
holy you know
um he's the blueprint for a lot of a lot
of music
but just to like he was on my last
project dirty computer and um just I
recorded him
talking we had just a conversation and
we were just talking about all the
heaviness this is somebody who's lived
in multiple Generations you know
somebody who was here uh pre-integration
and and got a chance to usher in
um
so revolutions you know with his music
and he just has stories that nobody has
right he probably does there's not a lot
of people who are walking this Earth who
can tell stories like him
yeah just a beautiful spirit and and um
yeah I love him I love him all right so
the album is out everybody age of
pleasure did we talk about how I did the
album how'd you do it okay so my friends
I was talking about that same party
everyday people they could not
um find a spot and so I offered our spot
Wonderland uh in L.A we have a spot in
Atlanta and now in L.A these like
creative spaces yeah creative space you
know Studio indoor outdoor Vibes and
um
I offered our spot and I was like let's
do like maybe 100 people
um test everybody is doing the pandemic
and the people who were at the party
again most beautiful brown and black
people from all over the globe from
Africa South Africa Ghana Nigeria
um Jamaica the Caribbeans New York L.A
Midwest like all of us together in a
safe space
and in the pandemic when you hadn't been
around people
reintegrating super weird it was just
like but it was like oh this is life
like this is what we fight to protect
right this is what we're missing that's
what we're missing I don't realize
you're missing it until yeah until you
and I was like okay I know I want to
make a soundtrack I want to make a
soundtrack to this lifestyle because I
want to see that Joy you know I
oftentimes our safe spaces
um
are
police come in shut it down
um and and to see us having that Joy
complete strangers getting to know each
other feeling so free uh was something
that I I only dream of and I always want
for everybody and so I just started
making the music
for the parties that was it I said tell
my DJ don't say it's me I'm gonna make
like two to three songs just play them
in the mix play it and if people are not
shazamming it's not going on the album
if people are going to go sit down it
will not make the album and that's how I
made um the age of pleasure with my
friends for my friends